Nos están pidiendo que factoricemos 20u al cuadrado por "v"
- 10 por "u" por "v" cuadrada ¿Ok? Y a lo que se refieren cuando nos piden que factoricemos, es a que tomemos
este binomio o cualquier expresión que nos estén impidiendo que factoricemos
y lo escribamos como un producto de otras dos expresiones.
Entonces vamos a ver si podemos hacer eso, y la forma más fácil de hacerlo es
encontrar factores comunes entre las expresiones que se están sumando o restando.
De hecho sabes que es mejor tomar el máximo común divisor de todos los términos
y después aplicar algo que sería así como la
inversa de la propiedad distributiva, que básicamente es dividir a cada uno de los términos entre el máximo común divisor
y después multiplicar a todo, por el mismo máximo común divisor que es lo que estamos factorizando de esta expresión.
Vas a ver a qué me refiero en unos cuantos segundos,
por lo pronto empecemos por encontrar el máximo común divisor de estos dos términos.
Entonces por lo menos al principio
hay que escribir cada uno de estos términos en su expresión más sencilla ¿Ok?
Buscando las partículas más
elementales que componen a esta multiplicación.
El video pasado se trataba de eso entonces, vamos a hacerlo un poquito más rápido.
Aquí 20 por "u" al cuadrado por "v", si lo queremos escribir lo más desarrollado posible
lo escribimos como
20 en su factorización en primos, que es simplemente 2 por 2 por 5
por la "u" cuadrada son 2 "u" multiplicándose entonces aquí ponemos "u" por "u"
y finalmente por "v" y de este lado tenemos aquí
10 cuya factorización en primos es 2 por 5
una sola "u"
una sola "u" y tenemos 2 "v" multiplicándose
entonces "v" por "v" muy bien. Ahora vamos a encontrar el máximo común divisor de estos 2 términos
entonces a ver, los 2 términos tienen un 2
entonces vamos a circularlo, aquí podría circular cualquiera de estos 2
los dos tienen un 5
Los dos tienen por lo menos una "u"
este término tiene 2 "u" pero este término solo tiene una entonces solo vamos a circular una
y los dos tienen por lo menos una "v" chica
ok entonces aquí tenemos que el máximo común divisor es 2 por 5 por "u" por "v"
y entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahora es escribir a cada uno de estos términos como
nuestro máximo común divisor por alguna otra expresión.
¿Ok? Pero vamos a aplicar el inverso de la propiedad distributiva de una vez por todas.
Aquí este término es el máximo común divisor que son todos estos cuatro círculos naranjas,
por 2 por "u" entonces, vamos a poner por aquí 2 por "u" de este lado
este término es el máximo común divisor
por "v".
Entonces a la hora de aplicar la propiedad distributiva en este paréntesis con este factor,
lo que nos queda es éste por éste que es este término de acá,
menos el máximo común divisor por "v" que es este término de acá,
Entonces estas dos expresiones son exactamente iguales y
además ya hicimos lo que nos están pidiendo,
ya lo escribimos como una multiplicación de 2 cosas, nuestro máximo común divisor y de este paréntesis.
Y para terminar deberíamos de simplificar este término entonces, nos queda 2 por 5, 10
y aquí tenemos una "u" y una "v", uv
Por 2u, 2u menos v
y pues aquí nos tomamos la molestia de poner todos los factores
de cada uno de estos términos por que estamos empezando
pero, lo que uno hace normalmente ya que entendió que es lo que estamos haciendo en el fondo,
es tomar estas expresiones y
calcularlo mentalmente ¿Cuál es el máximo común divisor?
¿Ok? Vamos a hacerlo entonces, uno dice ¡Ah! Tenemos 20 y tenemos 10
y el 10 divide al 20 entonces, el máximo común divisor entre 20 y 10 tiene que ser un 10,
y por aquí tenemos "u" cuadrada y "u"
y el máximo común divisor de estos dos entonces tiene que ser una "u",
y el máximo común divisor entre "v" y "v" cuadrada es una "v".
Entonces este es el máximo común divisor entre estos 2 términos
y entonces vamos a multiplicar el máximo común divisor por
20 por "u" cuadrada por "v" pero, vamos a dividir este término
entre nuestro máximo común divisor que es 10uv
y después tenemos
menos el otro término que es 10 por "u" por "v" cuadrada pero, también lo vamos a dividir
entre el máximo común divisor
10 por "u" por "v"¿Ok? Entonces lo que tenemos aquí, si aplicamos la propiedad distributiva nos queda
éste por éste pero, entonces éste se va a cancelar con éste
y nos va a quedar simplemente el primer término que es el término
morado, y después lo tenemos que restar éste por esto pero, entonces se va a cancelar éste con
éste, y nos va a quedar simplemente el numerador que es el segundo término,
así es que claramente estas 2 expresiones son iguales.
¿Ok? Pero esta expresión de aquí se puede simplificar más
porque estas expresiones
racionales tienen factores comunes, de hecho su factor común es 10 por "u" por "v"
pero bueno entonces tenemos aquí
20 entre 10
y de eso nos queda simplemente un 2
y por aquí tenemos "u" cuadrada entre "u" y nos queda simplemente "u",
la "v" se cancela con la "v"
y a eso le tenemos que restar 10 entre 10 es simplemente un 1,
eso es equivalente a decir que se cancelan
"u" entre "u" es otro 1 y "v" cuadrada entre "v"
nos queda simplemente una "v" por 1 por 1, que es simplemente una "v" y listo,
ya terminamos aquí, y obtuvimos
exactamente lo mismo ¿Ok? Factorizamos esta expresión como 10 por "u" por "v"
por entre paréntesis 2u menos v.